anyone who drives a car or trucks Goods
across the country has been dealing with
gas and diesel prices going up and down
throughout the year those price jumps
were largely a reaction to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and Western allies
subsequent sanctions on Moscow now more
price uncertainty is on the way that's
because a European Union ban on Russian
oil imports kicks in on December 5th
alongside that the group of seven and
some other countries have signed up to a
U.S pushed price cap on crude sales of
60 per barrel
both moves are intended to dent a key
Revenue stream for Russia while keeping
Global oil supplies flowing what could
that mean for prices at the pump
gas and diesel prices are higher on
average than a year ago but have been
trending down in recent weeks this could
change if Russia follows through of its
threat to stop exporting oil in response
to the price
Cape
is
Kremlin said it won't accept the price
cap and that it was assessing the
situation but the cap of 60 is above the
current trading price of Russian crude
so Supply cutoff may not be in Russian
President Vladimir Putin's best
interests the global diesel Market
though may be more sensitive to Market
effects that play out from the cap
stores of the fuel are low in the US
particularly on the East Coast which is
already competing with Europe for diesel
a problem that could become more acute
with any loss of Russian supplies Europe
has long relied on Russian refiners for
the fuel favored in sectors like
Agriculture and trucking if Russia holds
back exports or if European refiners
can't find replacements for Russian oil
the global market price for the fuel
could rise
and if diesel becomes more expensive the
cost of transporting goods or growing
produce could be passed on to Consumers
existing sanctions have so far had
limited impact on Russian oil production
nonetheless the US and some European
countries are preparing for any possible
supply drops
refiners gas stations and other buyers
got ahead of any Supply shortfalls
importing more diesel from Saudi Arabia
the United Arab Emirates and India U.S
refiners are currently well stocked with
crude so any impact on American
consumers wouldn't be felt for some time
according to one analyst treasury
secretary Janet Yellen said recently
that the U.S could draw further from the
country's strategic petroleum Reserve if
Russia cuts off its supplies and raises
Global prices
any immediate major Fallout from the
Embargo and the price cap appears
unlikely According to some analysts
and the average cost of fuel in the US
has fallen more than 30 from record
highs in the summer and experts say this
downward Trend will continue this means
as a chance Americans will be paying
less at the pump as they travel home for
Christmas than they did last year which
is around 3.85
the lower prices could be short-lived
though they tend to rise on a seasonal
basis starting in mid-February according
to GasBuddy China relaxing at zero
covered policy could also cause a price
spike as could any number of unforeseen
geopolitical tensions
the uncertainty in the oil Market is far
from over